me
それからわずか下げたん
これはなんだろバッハとに申し訳ございませんでした
俺に謝れ本当に多さはございませんでした
なあんなんでペンを鼻に入れてください
ダメっすよそんな汚いばしませんからね
ラブライブ本メンバー9人のうち誰が好きか教えてくださいさあさん僕ことにーちゃん
が一番好きだったんですけど最近ちょっとほのかちゃんのか気になりました
これを拭ってください
本当に辞めて本当にこういうのは飛びに思いっきり頭突きしてください本当に誰だって
ちょっと待って
誰だ得ながら本当に中としないかけってください
ああああああ
花に虫歯の詰めて下さい日都内の家なんだよ
止めをかっこいいことについてください兄は
ホルダーハート dc をつけた
法観寺車
頬杖後輩シャツは後腸炎できないんですかねはね色んなメンバーが出てきたと思うん
ですけれども
2もう大学が卒業が使いということでみんなそれぞれの進路に進んでいます
まあなんとか匠が動画に出て
でてもらってるくらいなんですけど
バンドメンバーみんな逸夫氏のに進んでて僕も迷惑かけたくないんでまずメンバー本当
に自分のしたいことを今涼んでるんで上からているということはないと言ってもらって
もいいと思います一緒にして
だあああああああ
違うか
違うんで俺のした行きたいオレかねぇ
私のスパゲッティ食べてますでしょも身が入ってるわけていっ
わー
バッハ
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
あああっひっ
ああ
を年白いなぁ賃金にカッコつける私たちの研究をされてください
ています
ぷっ
ん
10です食べの添え書きにいうとこんなもんダメなきゃな人生までの方ね新品だった
ねーっ
あっちょいすば前ちゃうして5 z 応募してください他の4つの一気になりますそれ
とベルンで飛んでからの倒立前転母の全通してから嘔吐してやる
アジャファーいった
ぽって
re
ポップカーズ
これもで気をすごく目薬んぐがマネーに右するとか
どうすれば絞ったら出るんですかね
は字幕をピークにして下さいお願いしますあとねええ十分行うひっくり返さないっすよ
このにメットすべてください肌に免許制そんなことするわけないっしょ
follow 切符しないピッチのみっ
うわぁああ大
文房具ピュアノア質問皆さんありがとうございました
もうそういうこの動画のコメント欄にしてくださいじゃなくて
いもういろんな登録から選ぶんでもう僕にコメントしちゃってください
いろんなコメントして答えたいなって思ったやつがあったらまとめてそれを
質問コーナーにするんであの本当にもコメントたくさんのみなさんありがとうね
なんでどんどんいろんな動画にコメントしてくださいちょっと笑えないんで終わります
じゃあな